Jimmy Kimmel's return as Oscar's host is
officially a win welcome to
Entertainment Tonight over 18 million
people watch the Oscars telecast of 12
from last year listen I said it Jimmy
was a 10 out of 10 and now we're
learning even more behind the scenes
gyms and drama too thanks to Maverick
missing in action
not today
I'm saving the movie industry
of Fred the Movie that saved the movies
about a three minute chunk dedicated to
Tom Cruise honoring his role in Reviving
the movie industry we were so
disappointed Jimmy really wanted to
celebrate him that's Kimmel's wife and
the Oscars executive producer Molly
McNerney who says if Tom showed up they
would have cut this Scientology joke Tom
Cruise with his shirt off in that Beach
football scene L Ron hubba hubba you
know what I'm saying we're definitely
overthinking every joke right now what
else was scrapped quote I cannot tell
you how many Will Smith jokes we got rid
of why we didn't think that was our
place that should be Chris Rock not us
do you want to come up here and get
jiggy with it you're going to have to
get through the Mandalorian Pedro Pascal
Andrew Garfield Michael B Jordan and
Michelle yeoh were all told just minutes
before Showtime they'd be a part of
Jimmy's opener but Colin Farrell Jessica
Chastain and Malala had no idea they'd
be singled out and speaking of cocaine
bear leave Malala alone everybody wants
to know who was in the cocaine bear
costume it was a celebrity that is
correct and that celebrity was
DJ Jazzy Jeff
[Applause]
[Music]
more behind the scenes show secrets
Brianna wasn't in her seat when the show
started and she originally wanted to
have her baby on her lap so Kimmel's
wife tells variety at the last second he
had to improvise Rihanna has a nine
month old backstage and he's very cute
one of the things that the world I guess
was focused on was this lady and her
headdress she was nominated for
co-writing the song Lift Me Up Lift Me
Up is also with the people sitting
behind her kept saying all night
Tim's response to the Dress drama oops
blushing emoji
foreign